what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell also get
yourself a women shouldn't vote shirt
today if you want all the women to come
up and talk to you and realize how
amazing you are make sure you get a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt as quickly
as you can okay so today I'm going to be
reacting to Big Tao which is men going
their own way so a lot of men have
really um just looked at this system
that we have and just said you know what
I am never getting married this this is
horrible you could lose your kids your
money everything you ever loved etc etc
so they're like you know what I'm okay
and I really think it's reasonable that
men come to this conclusion I really can
understand where they're coming from a
lot of people try to demonize them call
them in cells that's really not what I
find to be true I find it's a lot of
guys that got divorced and are like I am
never doing that again no ma'am no sir
no no no anyway so so um this mgtow
channel is called Sandman so we're gonna
react to now women can divorce you even
if you're not married let's let's pull
it up same man here this video isn't
brought to you by your Nations if you
want to send money for me to cover a
topic of your choosing then please do so
at the PayPal subscribe star Bitcoin
links below recently I was doing a
coaching call and one of my clients
mentioned that on Australia they have
something called de facto marriage where
if you live with a woman for two years
then you're automatically considered
married yeah this is what they do the
men keep trying to not sign up for
marriage and they keep trying to legally
screw them like women we always just
want to extract as many resources from
the men as possible so the men are like
okay we're not going to do the legal
thing honey we can just live together
and the women are like oh no lawmakers
please pass some laws so we can still
get that money please and she has a
right to have your assets in New Zealand
it's three years and in Canada it's six
months to a year of cohabitation and
then she can technically divorce you
because according to the state you're
technically married five to nine years
ago I was doing a photography job for a
bunch of family divorce court lawyers
and judges and one of their judges was
retiring so they were giving him a big
send-off I got to talking with one of
the lawyers and asked him if there was a
Slowdown considering that most people
were living together these days and not
getting married he said that they were
going to change the laws over to common
law couples living together having the
same consequences or similar
consequences as married couples there
you go yeah this is why I say there's no
way for a man to legally interact with a
woman and not have a consequence a year
later they did that in British Columbia
where people are technically married
after one year of cohabitation I've
heard some states it's like three months
Canada goes even further and there was a
story about a guy in Toronto that was
with a woman and not even living with
her but simply because people thought
that they were married he was forced to
pay alimony by the courts what
like this is this is so nutty and this
is why guys I I understand why dudes
don't want to get married and why they
don't even want to have relations with
us at all because this is crazy the
price is too high for the value they get
even though they never married or lived
together but I look at this idea of de
facto marriage as something that may
actually benefit men men need to start
practicing hypergamy pretending to have
assets while dating women that actually
have more than they do living with a
woman for two years and then leaving her
and getting the courts involved to take
her cash in prizes hey hey let's not
make that a trend let it's not let's not
do that if not becomes popular there
might be films in the future with
couples trying to get together and are
both secretly broke thinking that the
other one has money so they can spring a
de facto divorce just over the two-year
Mark living together there might be a
professional divorce or class after each
divorce you hide your assets in Bitcoin
or Monero and it looks like you have
nothing on paper until you find your
next victim you could basically be
another version of the Tinder swindler I
found a few people discussing this issue
in a post on the men's rights Reddit
that said this and I quotes his
ex-girlfriend entitled to have of
ex-boyfriend's assets in New Zealand if
you live with your girlfriend for more
than three years she is entitled to half
your assets if the relationship breaks
off it's called the de facto
relationship there's a case in question
with Israel adesanya a mixed martial
arts fighter from Nigeria now in New
Zealand citizen his ex-girlfriend is
also a New Zealand citizen she has
dragged him through court for half of
his assets they do not have children no
were they married Google slash YouTube
the story for more information beware
this is yet another example of why you
should avoid cohabitation in Australia
it's two years I heard a guy the way he
does it is he makes the girl pay the
rent
because he wants to avoid any like
issues and I guess there's some legal
work around where if the woman pays the
rent then it like works I don't know New
Zealand three years in Canada six months
are there any other countries you're
aware of that have similar rules slash
consequences for men unquotes I'll try
to answer down in moments but let me
first tell everyone about today's
sponsor anyways now back to don't live
with women in Australia are there
kangaroo courts might award her half
your life savings clown world show
Israel addisonia has said that his
assets are protected like okrafukini the
football player where his wife actually
wanted his money but he had nothing
because he put it in his mother's name
although I highly doubt that Israel put
his money in his mother's name his
ex-girlfriend Charlotte poundrell from
New Zealand wants to take it Sonia a
Nigerian to the cleaners Nigerians are
oftentimes stereotypes as being con
artists and I find it ironic that a
white woman from New Zealand is trying
to scam him hopefully he gets out of it
financially did you hear that let me put
on that phone
Kings Nigerian
guys
Nigerians are oftentimes stereotypes as
being con artists and I find it ironic
that a white woman from New Zealand is
trying to scam him hopefully
he gets out of it financially unscathed
he's even said that she entered the
relationship with nothing and now wants
to leave with Millions he was swearing a
lot in his comments and I think that's
going to work against him if this
actually goes to courts the manosphere
is known about this de facto marriage
thing for years now and now the normies
know about it too because it's happening
to a celebrity what this is going to do
is discourage people from living
together and therefore less babies will
be born as a result I predict that
eventually guys will adapt and the
lawyers too and make it so that if you
have a girlfriend for maybe three or six
months regardless of if you're living
with or not she's entitled to half your
asset yeah they're gonna keep doing in
this is that true or no would you say
Nigerians typically like is that like a
stereotype the scamming thing isn't that
crazy though how they're like it's like
guys walk away from marriage and they
just change the laws to make it like
less and less the lawyers are not
feminists will have killed them how
ironic is that I also heard the de facto
marriage is legal in seven U.S states
but I couldn't confirm anything under
the Reddit post another guy in the land
down under said this and I quotes I live
here and it is legal I had a friend who
bought an apartment with his inheritance
from his grandparents he lived with his
girlfriend for two years in it I
remember his parents being worried that
if they broke up she would try and take
half his apartment it's ridiculous the
key question is determination of start
date of the relationship you may not
have been living together for three
years but if she can prove that you were
together as a couple for a minimum of
three years he is screwed unquotes that
guy spoke to my coaching call also
mentions that there's something like 10
criteria and if you meet only one or two
two of them then you're considered de
facto married and she can have halfo de
facto other guys in Australia are
figuring out ways to adapt to this and
some are saying not to move in together
and if she pressures you for
cohabitation then that should be a major
red flag one guy was also wondering if
men can claim women pressuring them to
move in together as coercive control
[Laughter]
men for coercive control by saying they
pressured us into doing things we didn't
want to do how many men could argue that
they have been pressured into marriage
and children when they didn't want to do
it oh that is such a good point using
the same phrases women do and if it's
proven in court that he was coerced to
cohabitate that she doesn't deserve half
of his stuff but for my photography gig
with those lawyers and judge of as they
are pretty much buddy buddy and if a
woman has to pay a man a divorce
settlement then the lawyers make money
and so does the government with tax
dollars so obviously there's a conflict
of interest here just as Global
fertility rates are crashing this will
add even more downside I just read that
in Italy they're down to 1.25 kids per
woman I'm predicting someone fertility
rates in the country in the next 10
years as the league wow wait that's so
crazy I'm predicting someone fertility
rates in the country in the next 10
years as the latest generation of young
guys learn about female nature online
but it's getting scary out there that's
going to be such a crazy world so like
imagine sub one fertility rate making
money and staying in the middle class is
harder than ever I can't wait to see how
lawyers will respond to AI girlfriends
and lover Bots that cause marriage rates
to plummet to 10 or 20 percent of the
population that's the thing I think King
I think that marriage is like a rich
person's game now I feel like the middle
class are the ones that are going to
walk away from Marriage the only people
that are going to be married or the rich
like I think because those are the only
one that it seems to work out for
because I think the divorce rate from
Rich guys is like 75 like it's 75 don't
get divorced you know it's like what's
the woman gonna do replace him good luck
you know I feel like the middle class
because and those guys like a lot of
Rich guys kind of look at I I think look
at marriage is just like an expense like
they're like okay whatever this is if it
goes wrong this is what I'm going to
spend on it whatever then they just keep
on moving but it's like the middle class
guys that are like no no I'm not working
for 20 years and and doing that much
prevention but how oh that's gonna be
such a weird world it's already kind of
a weird world like it's weird because I
look around and I think about like how I
grew up and I feel like it happened like
right before my eyes but I just didn't
even notice it like when I was a kid
there was families everywhere and I know
you can go into like some places and
there there's more but it's like there's
always like one kid maybe two kids a lot
of single mothers now but when I was
growing up like you know there's at
least a good amount of families that
still have four or five like I could
think you know my my family had um when
I was there sex and I could think of
like a lot of families that also had
like maybe not six but like five four
three but now it's just like one kid
maybe two and if you go to a lot of
places they used to have families it's
like childless couples a lot
cohabitation from ever happening the
lawyers have been wrecking marriage to
make a buck in the Here and Now what
creative solution will the blood sucking
divorce lawyers look for to save their
industry at that point my thinking is
that they'll get on the bandwagon to
band technologies that free men from
women and therefore lower the birth rate
uh wow that's an interesting way to look
at it and I've heard the mgtow because
the mgtow point of view is that which is
kind of like sad but it's like that AI
girlfriends and porn free men from women
so they don't have to deal with these
systems so they kind of see it as like
this stuff like frees us from these
crazy batch women which is fair when you
kind of look at the numbers also
remember that historically the majority
of politicians were lawyers before they
became career politicians oh wow that's
that's an thing if your job involves
passing legislation then it certainly
helps if you have a law background so
you know what the hell you're doing so
that means that other lawyers and judges
are buddy buddy with politicians and ah
that actually makes a lot of sense some
cases so that'll mean they'll help them
out if they start running out of work
but at some point they'll no longer be
able to squeeze blood from a stone and
they're a whole house of cards built
around a woman's hole will come crashing
down the worst part about all of this is
that it's retroactive and it's all about
changing the goal posts if 20 years ago
you looked the law and realized the
cohabitation and non-marriage is
perfectly fine and you weren't going to
get divorce raped because you were never
married then you jump right in yeah
that's the thing like guys used to marry
chicks in three months they literally
used to just like yeah they would be
like all right this chick's hot I love
her let's get married but that's because
one the women offered a lot more value
and the risk wasn't so high if it went
South it's like all right you know I
mean it sucks but a lot of guys would
get primary custody now it's like she
can just destroy me mentally financially
and the children as well slowly over
time without even realizing if the laws
change and you don't get grandfathered
in with the old laws which should happen
and instead you get subjected to the new
ones that's what makes this unfair
because the rules change so just imagine
today you have a girlfriend and you
don't live with her and think you're
safe just imagine how simply dating her
for six months might be enough to warn a
divorce we're almost at the point where
men are just going to walk away and not
take any risks because it means that the
rules can change at a moment's notice
and your past can now cost your future
it's a catch-22 situation for the
government and lawyers because on one
side they want people to get married
make babies and replace themselves then
get divorced the divorce lawyers can
make their money why do you think they
legalize gay marriage in the first place
they probably saw it as a new frontier
for well and the other thing is too I
always say I just really I don't see
families coming back I don't see birth
rates like I don't see any of this
change until they take away power from
women and the tough thing is is like how
do you get rid of power when women are
mostly like the biggest voting block so
if they need women to win elections then
how how do you get power away from women
what incentive do the lawmakers have to
switch it but at the same time I and
this is why I I I have a tough time
because people think I'm like so
pessimistic I just don't really see
another alternative until you fix the
system that's like the only way I see it
because when women have leverage like we
see what happens when women have
leverage when they win the lottery they
divorce their husbands when we got the
opportunity to leave we do and you could
argue okay you know I mean there's a
good women here and there yeah sure but
remember like women's nature is still
our nature like we still are a certain
way and this isn't new right we just
always had systems to protect men from
women's crazy and really women's crate
like systems to protect women from our
own crazy a lot of times we hurt
ourselves in the process
um and so so I just don't know if I see
another alternative family law to
pillage people's pocketbooks if the gays
were still cheering at all thinking that
the system was willing to give them
equal rights and Status meanwhile I had
more to do with the potential to get the
state in their bedrooms and wreck their
Scissor Sisters and booty pirate fun men
will do a [__] benefit analysis in the
future and realize that even if you
don't have a metaphorical sort of
Damocles hanging over your head today
when it comes to your relationships that
doesn't mean it won't be snuck over your
head when you aren't looking it's really
sad what's happening it's only gonna
they really just need to get the
government out of relationships there
should actually be zero tax that like
all these incentives gotta go like the
more I think about it like because when
you get like think about this guys this
system has changed the way men and women
interact with each other it has changed
like even I I spoke to Aaron pizzi the
other day and she was telling me how um
you know men used to like whistle when
you walked by and that was seen as like
a compliment now they don't do it
because of the legal consequences so
it's like this has changed and I look at
like harmless like flirting like videos
from like 50 years ago right where it's
like the masculine and the fat it's like
really cute and I'm like you don't
really see that anymore you don't see
like you know men don't want to be
creepy they don't want to be like
weirdos they don't want a video of them
on Tick Tock going viral saying they're
quote unquote creepy they don't want to
get in trouble for this stuff so it
literally changes the way we interact so
we just gotta get the government out of
this stuff that that is the only
solution I see because men are really
good this is the benefit this is the
cost they weigh it and you know the the
bigger we make the cost of marriage and
women and all this stuff the the more
likely it's we're just not we're gonna
keep seeing the birth rate plummet
honestly get worse as more women enter
political office and craft all sorts of
new laws to punishments exactly this is
why we got to get women outside out of
office get them out we do not belong
with the devouring mother archetype
trying to micromanage men and wreck Our
Lives anyways that's it for today don't
forget to smash the like button the way
that in the future men will smash robots
and the state will still try and find a
way to take their assets away
um yeah I mean I I really I think make I
think mgtow guys make a lot of sense
it's really not a happy ending right and
I and I think that's that's unfortunate
because it's like you know we watch
Disney there's all these Happy Endings
but we're in a decline and the only
solution I see I really think if Trad
cons want to be taken seriously if the
right and the left really want families
to come back we really got to change the
laws that's the only solution I see uh
but let me know what you guys think um
in the and you know what's also
unfortunate it's like my generation of
women didn't do any of this we didn't
make any of these laws same with the men
but it's like we all grew up in this
[__] up system and it's unfortunate
because it's really going to change the
entire world you know but let me know
what you guys think in the comments like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel I'll talk to you next time